bell a droit à ses jours j'aime pas
james bond et dans votre ville vous dise
morten tu te souviens on doit danser
pour papa et maman tu te rappelles que
c'est tes parents pas les noms qu'est ce
que c'est que cette façon d'écrire
dans ma famille a que des aventuriers
mon arrière arrière grand père était un
pirate
mon père a fait le tour de la terre et
moi je serai capitaine
un jour je t'emmènerai en mer avec moi
je veux venir avec toi
je suis le capitaine et j'abandonnerai
pomme l'équipage et le navire
je dirais à embêter m'opposer il embête
pas vous sortiez de votre papa quand
est-ce que tu reviens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais peut-être qu'on te donne un
petit moment et je suis le capitaine
c'est moi qui donne les ordres le noir
et le corps et youtube c'est moi qui
tire les ficelles
mais qui êtes vous du manger
tranquillement soleil coup quelque chose
mais je dis dans ce trou tout son celui
qui a fait ça n'a peut-être pas compris
ce qu'il faisait
salut les compagnies alors vous ne
pouvez pas payer pour la pension de
mortain mais vous êtes propriétaire d'un
bateau qu'il faut de l'argent
mon papa lé là devant leur vendre le
bateau et voilà ce qui vous revient il
faut y retourner mais c'est dangereux
[Musique]
genre à réparer les buts ischio jambiers
là de retour parmi nous et pas sur moi
attribue la mort accrochez vous
[Musique]
bats toi